only fans models sex workers feel a
pinch of the sluggish economy i'm
working harder than ever okay the
plunging economy has been hard on one
particular sector sex workers who say
that the that the decades high inflation
has forced their clients to cut back on
discretionary spending ali ray a 38 year
old massachusetts woman who left her 84
000 a year nursing job to earn a monthly
six-figure income on only fans told the
post on friday that she and other online
creators have seen their incomes take a
hit recently many top recreators are
hurting bad race ad it's definitely
something that's happening
rey who during the pandemic earned as
much as two hundred thousand dollars a
month told the post that her income has
fallen 25 in the recent weeks other only
fans performers have seen incomes drop
by as much as 50 percent my traffic has
been down a lot i'm working harder than
i have ever been
so
my question
for today to start is only fans a real
job
it is because you've got an income but
it's not when you think about it okay
what do you guys think
i think it is a real job it is a real
job any any any job where
you have to
um
[Music]
you have to display a form of talent on
something then and you earn your income
from
um
can be considered work you know it's
just the platform that they're using it
on okay
i i think it's it's a job they are
providing the service at the end of the
day and they're getting paid for that
service therefore is a job how long term
a job is it's another question but yeah
it's basic form it's a job
i think the longevity is kind of
irrelevant if you have a a regular
income from something that you're doing
that does classify as a job
because it's more of a physical job like
it's like saying you're a model like
the longevity is not long like
your age you'll catch up or whatever
it's kind of like only fans models like
it will it's not like a long-term job
but it is a stable income for the time
being as you're doing it
so
yeah
it's definitely a job the sex worker is
definitely a job they work very hard
they do
would you say do you think they work
hard they do but i agree i do agree
having to like pretend someone is like
if i you know you have to pretend to be
pleasurable you know you could be going
for something in your life and i've got
go and perform on stage in my room to
camera and be like i'm loving this when
you're not so anxious it's yeah it's
hard work you know it's hard work being
a plumber an engineer yeah an
electrician yeah
only fans yeah taking your clothes off
on camera yeah but they also it's not
like being a prostitute on the street
you also have to market what you do like
they are freelancers essentially so they
have to
what's it
but a lot of street marketers as well
they market themselves they're just on
their own but in the sense of you have
to
think about it from a business point of
view like how am i going to market
myself to
maximize my potential income whereas if
you're a prostitute on the street like
there's only so much you can do tell me
tell me an early fans marketing strategy
i'm not on only
all the porn sites put a little bit of
15 50 second teaser that sounds like a
lot of hard work it is not hard i mean i
make i make programs for a living they
aren't hard work it's fun but it's hard
work so for me maybe i'm thinking about
as a talent point of view or some
production point of view
um some people are not good at sex
definitely a talent it's not a talent
not everyone's good at that
but wait obviously you have to remember
you're not just having sex in it so
we're talking about the generalized idea
of what goes on only friends you're not
just banging in it so like there's the
more artistic expression of the nice
pictures in the lingerie and blah blah
blah
banging someone on camera doesn't
require talent yes you're good at it
banging someone on camera
so you have to be good at it and not
everyone's good at sex or orgasm and
women and it's more of like the acting
thing like you need the person to
believe it like
it's not the same but a lot of only fans
created they're very similar to actors
like if they don't believe it they're
not all of it it's amateur
because if you look at brazil oh wait
say it you could call it let's say
quarantine
oh yeah you could say that about any
actor who's had their first lead role
though that's amateur action isn't it
because it's their first big so so i'm
just got a question we're going to put
mia khalifa okay as the same thing as
like johnny depp in terms of talent yeah
well no because obviously johnny depp is
doing like talented he's no he's doing
different talented he's talented yes but
then there's some things that
me and khalifa could do that i'm
obviously she's talented there's
something girls can do like
what makes her talented it's talent what
makes her talented
i mean i don't know that okay some
certain people that are sex workers that
perform
they do things i cannot do
and that's the fact okay because i've
seen it and i'm like how are you how are
you like because tommy because we could
do good deep throating huh i can't do
that i just actually don't know
and that makes her talented um it's a
talent because i can't do it
and i've tried
and i still couldn't do it so you know
the breathing techniques the
breathing techniques
so what so swimmers make good deep
frothers
i hope so
it's the angle it's just the angle
that's it okay so
so in your head do you feel like only
fans requires a lot of talent no i'm not
saying quite a lot of talent okay i'm
saying that a little bit i'm saying that
they work hard in the sense that they
have to you know even look good go to
the gym and keep right the hair's going
right what they invest in themselves is
a lot so when you put all the investment
they're putting for them
are born hot thank you and uh they're
just but wait yeah but you could you
could literally say that about a model
if you've got it flaunt it like you're
acting like you need to hide what does
it mean to have a talent like let's
define this word talent because you
could chuck in the one yeah there's a
lot does it mean
i mean
well i mean these days it's not much
because influence is all over the place
and they're saying the talent what i
would say what i'd say is anything that
anybody can do
it doesn't require talent only fans is
something that anybody can do therefore
you're not talented to be an only friend
you could literally say anyone could be
an actor anyone could be a singer
no not anybody can like we use johnny
depp as an example yeah
these are two top range people in the
industry
one is clearly talented
just get banged on camera there's a
difference yeah i mean they're just
being banned on camera they're making
less you're trying to create nuances to
something that doesn't really exist is
it just it no she's getting banged on
camera okay yes i should get banned on
camera but not every girl can do that
someone says talented every girl can get
back no no no it's not everything is
hard work no like no not every girl
chooses to do that
but not every girl is gonna stoop low
enough to do that i don't know if it's
about being low because it is low
because that's that's that's that's
some girls earned you with their
boyfriends and that's it
man and then no but these girls actually
do do that but even if you do it with
your boyfriends you're thinking short
term like because think about it those
girls are going to get married one day
is it to their boyfriends if it's not to
their boyfriends what's on the internet
forever then one day they're going to
have kids they're not thinking about
their kids yeah it's not a long term
thing but it's literally like at least
in today's society like everyone's very
money hungry and it's such a quick rich
scheme like it really why can't we be
money hungry you go to engineering
because you don't get the same amount as
you would like
but look at the example that we're
talking about we use mia khalifa as an
example we talked about the the
byproduct of participating and stuff
like sex mickey leifer wants all the
stuff off the internet she's paid stupid
amounts of money to remove her stuff off
the internet and she still can't do it
and not only that it's harmed her
ability to stay in a long-term
relationship she wants to be she wants
to be in a long-term normal relationship
all the people keep doing they spam her
boyfriend with porn videos that she used
to do so now she's utterly speaking on
what she experienced in the industry and
she's letting girls know this is not
something that's conducive to successful
life so all this short term like fast
money comes with slow problems
and that's a fact so a lot of people are
sitting there thinking okay yeah
everyone's money hungry you still have
to do the right things to make that
money right and the wrong way to do
things but everyone's getting banged on
camera some girls literally just they're
by themselves and they're just but in
lingerie cooking now not everyone is
going to those aren't the big money
makers but
i mean i don't know the stacks of only
fans but not everyone has to have sex on
camera to make my own fans or whatever
they're doing but let's not talk about
exceptions to the rules yeah let's let's
be specific here most of the people and
only fans do it for sex work right
they're sex workers so most people that
are only fans do it for sex work right
yeah so let's stick to that narrative
then yeah instead of
normally just
like
like banging there's so much things to
say yeah sex work i'm talking about sex
work anything to do with sex work i'm
talking about okay fine all of it okay
cool